For this question, I'd like you to calculate the time the data spends at routers
on its trip between two points.
The trace route we're going to take is between me here in Birmingham, England,
and Mid Sweden University.
Now, because I'm using Windows my tracer route is "tracert"
instead of the whole word "traceroute," which was what Dave used on the Mac
and also on Linux.
This trace route doesn't go directly to Sweden.
It actually goes via The Netherlands and Denmark.
There we have NL Netherlands, DK Denmark, SE Sweden.
Finally it's at Mid Sweden University, and it takes about 75 milliseconds,
and we're going to use that value.
Traceroute--and remember that that's the round trip time from Birmingham, England,
to Sundsvall in Sweden-takes 75 millisends.
Now, in order to do this calculation, we're going to need to know the distance.
So the one way distance from Birmingham to Sundsvall--now this isn't a direct distance.
It's the distance via The Netherlands and Denmark just like the traceroute took.
It's about 2,500 km.
What you're also going to need to know is the speed of light.
That's what we take the speed the data travels at in optical fiber.
That's about two-thirds the speed of light, which is 200,000 km/sec.
That's the speed that you're going to need for the data between the routers.
What I would like to know is what is the total time spent at the routers.
If you'd like to enter your answer in the box here.
One more thing you might need to know is that there are 1,000 milliseconds in 1 second,
and please make sure that you're answer is given in milliseconds.
You can give it to the nearest whole number or any number of decimal places that you like.